hello everyone and welcome to today's
vibe pod cast seeing through the
murrhardt quantitative 3d assessment of
myocardial ischemia reperfusion injury
and response presented by Simon Mertz
Institute for experimental immunology
and imaging s in Germany I'm Christie
julibrissin I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminars rescued by labyrinth and
sponsored by you Morris for more
information on our sponsors please visit
Mrs calm now let's get started I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
down at the top-right of the
presentation window or let us know
you're experiencing a problem by using
the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and the
software continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit to have located at the top right
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credits I
would now like to introduce our speaker
Simon Murch Institute for experimental
immunology and imaging s in Germany and
joining us for our live Q&A we have
Sebastian Kosta University Hospital SM
Germany for complete biographies on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
Simon you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody and special thanks to
Amara supporting this broadcast and
welcome to the webinar my name is Simon
I am a third year PhD in the Institute
for experimental immunology and imaging
in Essen Germany today I would like to
talk about how we came to see through
the mirror and heart if you would like
to read more about the topic the paper
was published recently in Nature
communications this project was a
collaboration between us and the
department of cardiology and vascular
medicine in the University Hospital s
but let's start at the beginning so why
do we actually want to see through the
mirror and heart what gold we hope to
reach first of all why do we look at the
mirror not at all so the background here
is myocardial infarction which is still
a very very lethal disease accountable
for over 9% of all death in the EU 28 in
2050 this is more or less true around
the globe so a lot of people suffer a
myocardial infarction each year
therefore a lot of research is conducted
to understand the biology behind
myocardial infarction to investigate the
associated immunological response in
order to come up with new drugs
eventually in this project we worked
with a mouse model close to the clinical
reality and ischemia reperfusion model
here in the living animal one coronary
artery is occluded via a knot that is
pulled tight for 45 minutes and using a
schema and downstream in the muscle
which is no longer perfused after 45
minutes the lot is loosened and
reperfusion is allowed for 24 hours or
longer times similar to placing a stent
after this time the heart is then
excised and analyzed this is when you
are exactly facing the read out problem
what do you actually want to know
because you have to decide if you want
to know about in function parameters
like which regions are damaged which
were still perfused during ischemia etc
the heart is typically sliced into two
millimeter thick slices for a red ox
tDCS a I explain that in more detail
later however besides giving you
information about the
extent of the damage this approach
yields no information on settler
identity or localization whatsoever
therefore you can cut the heart or your
TDC slice a bit more and do ordinary
2-dimensional sectioning which gives you
them limited information on cellular
identity location and quantity but very
limited to a two dimensional space or
you take the entire heart dissociated
completely and do flow cytometry this
will give you a quantitative overview of
your successfully prepared and stained
cell populations without any
localization context at all so if you
are in need of all these information
together you have to have multiple
animal groups introducing you a lot of
variability in the testing therefore we
wanted to establish a quantitative whole
organ multiplex imaging approach
assessing myocardial infarction that
brings us to the question how do we
actually look inside an opaque organ so
let's assume you have treated the mice
with drug that you want to test you can
also inject floor for conjugated
antibodies IV into the living Mouse
shortly before exercising the heart the
heart itself even after thorough
perfusion is quite reddish but you can
see on the lower left side now this
changes into grey once the heart is
chemically fixed next we remove all the
water from a sample by dehydrating it in
an ascending ethanol series with all the
water gone we can match the refractive
index of the sample with ether as
cinemate the non toxic organic solvent
this minimizes scattering of light as it
passes through the sample rendering the
sample transparent however the heart
muscle is still densely packed with
residual enricher sites or pigments like
myoglobin which block the last way and
these ingenious substances are not only
blocking the light they are also very
odd for us so in this example we
illuminated a cleared whole heart from
the side and took an overview image
longer wavelengths pen can penetrate
deeper into tissue so
the signal intensity from right to left
as year and histogram is not severely
dropping we also say the redder the
better however this is quite different
when assessing tissue autofluorescence
with shorter excitation wavelength like
five six one nanometers here in the
middle and gray or even much worse using
foreign 88 nanometers on the left hand
side using linear display we don't even
see the inner muscle only a bright halo
of autofluorescence at the edge of the
tissue having such gradients and
illumination and emission intensity
throughout the sample prohibits any
approach for quantitative assessment
therefore we compared different
bleaching protocols which destroy
pigments and odd forest molecule within
the sample so that we get in a better
overview we tried suit and black
bleaching which turned to sample
completely black rendering hole mount
imaging absolutely impossible what works
for brain slices does not seem to work
in a whole organ approach with him
illusion the bleaching step of the cubic
protocol which is another clearing
approach using aqueous solutions the
sample became much clearer
however we observed spots in the muscle
tissue and higher order fluorescence in
the channels we actually wanted to use
for quantification once we cleared the
heart in DC I therefore in contrasts the
published balanced approach is capable
of homogenizing the tissues of
fluorescence and results in transparent
samples furthermore it is fluent for
compatible so IV injected floor for cup
of antibodies can still be detected
afterwards so with this bleaching
approach hearts become white and once
immersed in DC I rapidly cleared as you
see in this time-lapse video spanning
about 30 minutes we term the process
balance which stands for bleaching or
mental solvent based non toxic hearing
talents as I showed before and this
completes the picture lowers therefore
and homogenizes tissue on fluorescence
in all channels which is a prerequisite
for quantitative imaging
so to answer the initial question of
masks but we can look inside an opaque
organ using a pigment bleaching step for
homogenous imaging coupled with tissue
clearing now that we have the Argan
clear we use light cheap fluorescence
microscopy in short lsfm to image an
entire argument with single-cell
resolution so in Alice afem we apply an
up to 4 micrometer thin sheet of light
perpendicular to the objective this
planar illumination leads to very very
selective excitation of the sample
reducing photo bleaching we also acquire
the whole field of view simultaneously
which reduces acquisition time the
sample itself as you see here in this
cartoon on the right hand side is then
moved through the applied laser sheet
and this is how we get the fast
recordings of image techs consisting of
two-dimensional optical slices that can
quite easily be turned into
three-dimensional constructions by the
use of appropriate software like for
example Mars what you see now in the
lower left M is such a stack of
two-dimensional optical slices of the
Arctic valve
we are viewing it from above looking
into the left ventricle in both
two-dimensional and three-dimensional
representations you can appreciate the
fine structure of three valves cusps
also take note of the detail of the
vessels that surround the valve so now
we're looking at the entire heart and we
always image the hearts as one no
cutting involved here you see a
three-dimensional reconstruction of the
dorsal side of the neuron heart
based on those resins and c31 stain
which is an endothelial marker we can
clearly distinguish the right and the
left ventricle and the Muslim walls the
appendages and they are art away the
erotic valves are also visible so if we
have a closer look on the left
ventricular wall we see a homogeneous
autofluorescence signal throughout the
muscle yielding enough contrast to
distinguish even singer cells most
likely cardiomyocytes
if you have a very close look you
can even spots dimmer or forest regions
that might represent Bluegreen also with
bleaching you see still some spots of
high autofluorescence left and in the
enlargement below you see that these
spots also attributes to certain single
cells but we don't know what causes it
yet however in general we have a good
overview and therefore with bleaching
clearing and imaging technicalities
established we started to bring my
accountant in faction parameters to
three-dimensional level since we want to
establish a multiplex approach we need
to determine what we are able to
visualize Immelt Aeneas Li for a solid
LS of M is capable of answering multiple
questions alone typically as mentioned
before cardiologists also and then also
other researchers studying schema
confusion perform the tDCS a a heart is
there sliced into thick sections in
which three major zones can be
distinguished the remote zone is the
part of the heart muscle that was still
confused during ligation to label it
blue as you see here in the coronary
artery
that was occluded to induce ischemia the
first place is relegated so closed again
before cutting the heart into slices and
evens blue a dye is pressed through the
aorta staining everything that is
perfused the TDC sa then itself is a
redox reaction fresh tissue
so if cells are where metabolically
active during excision of the heart TDC
becomes red so the part of the red
tissue that is Evans blue negative is
termed the area at risk this area was
not perf used during archery occlusion
but most cells survived and are still
metabolically active within this zone
that's the real ischemia reperfusion
injury in which TDC cannot be reduced to
its red form marking the damaged or dead
cells white so having understood this
and in order to reproduce these
parameters in 3d
we performed the ordinary ischemic
fusion challenge excised the heart
relegated the artery and filled the
heart with Fitz albumin instead of even
blue this led to an easily
distinguishable perfused remote zone
which is fitzy positive and a fitzy
negative non perfused zone the area or
better and the scant volume at risk note
that the area at risk is below the knot
where we actually suspect it to be the
total heart muscle volume was obtained
by segmenting tissue autofluorescence
alone and this is always much better to
view in a video so this video shows
that's exam X the second this exact same
thing in three dimensions using Amaris
so a reconstruction of the tissues or
fruss tigre gives us a representation of
the entire heart muscle so on one side
you can spot the knot used to occlude
the artery the corresponding
segmentation is white with such a
three-dimensional reconstruction we can
now look at the muscle layer at the
muscle tissue layer by layer in a
three-dimensional environment note that
we also see some other present sponsors
a tissue
even after bleaching the fitzy signal is
shown in cyan know that we clearly see
the fits positive remote zone and the
non profused
area at risk which is fitzy negative in
this three-dimensional segmentation now
of the autofluorescence here gray and
the area at risk shown in orange now
allows us to quantify the heart muscle
volume as well as the volume and
relative location of the area and risk
in summary using just two channels fitzy
and tissue or fluorescence in five six
one nanometer excitations we are able to
simultaneously quantify the area at risk
and the heart muscle volume respectively
but what about the damage so here a
paper from 2017 described impaired mice
cameras to look in stroke brains and
therefore we thought that we could take
a look at the vasculature in the mirror
and heart as well using
as I said before CD 31 also known as PK
1 as a marker for the aphelion to
investigate the basement state we
injected floor for coupled ante CD 31
antibodies IV into a control mouse prior
to the excision of the heart and that's
what we found very very densely packed
homogeneous lis distributed blood
vessels and what you see that here is
one single optical slice on the left and
the small three-dimensional
reconstruction of the different muscle
walls so a very structured vascular
network as expected right having such an
orderly mess the decimal meshwork in
basal untreated hearts we were
interested in quantifying systems
complexity in 3d now so therefore we
used a filament model approach and we
found that there is a total vessel
length density of 2.2 meters per cubic
millimeter so it's a lot of lot of cable
basically within the left ventricular
wall and this is about twice as much
within the brain so as a measure of
complexity we determined the vessel
length between two branch points to be
107 micrometers in average knowing this
we looked at the IR anyway hearts after
24 hours of reperfusion and here we
found a hole in the micro vasculature
while vessels outside of this 631
negative zone are still arranged and
only fashion taking a closer look we
find that c31 positivity is mainly lost
in smaller vessels while the larger ones
survive
this matches also with the findings in
the brain paper as well
however CV 31 negativity is the absolute
lack of any staining compared to c31 dim
regions which are enlarged in the upper
right here so interestingly these match
with highly odd 4s and randomly shaped
and distributed regions of yet unknown
identity anyway we use the border
between C 31 positive and negative
microvessels to trace and thus quantify
the IR injury
this brings us back on track so on
average the ir injury assists by CA 31
negativity takes up about 4% of the
total urine heart when we looked at the
hearts after five days of perfusion we
again encountered a change pattern so
the size of the ir injury was
drastically decreased the CD 31 negative
region was surrounded by seemingly
chaotic c 31 positive vessels so we
turned that region c 31 curly it is the
area within the dashed white line here
looking at the three-dimensional
structure of this zone we found a
reduced vessel length density but a
doubled complexity interestingly we
found that the volume of the CD one
curly region amounts approximately to
the size of the eye our injury after 24
hours of reperfusion giving us
technically speaking a proxy of where
the damage has been four days before and
this is of course very interesting when
we look at immune cells later so we see
a loss of CD 31 staining within blood
vessels but that does that have anything
to do with the actual damage that has
been assessed for decades to address
this we challenged miles with ischemia
reperfusion injected floor 4 cup with
antibodies CD third and so on t CD 31 IV
into mais 10 minutes before excision
slice the profuse hearts and perform to
TDC red ox staining and afterwards we
took the exams slices and cleared them
to do correlative lsfm using see if that
one as a marker here we see what the TVC
slices of an exemplary heart looked like
with the white zone being the damaged
tissue regions when assessing this in
Lachi first microscopy using c 31 as a
marker we found that c 31 negative zones
overlapped with TDC negative tissue
areas this is underlined by the good
correlation of TC negative and C 31
negative regions personalize and percent
However
TDC plan imagery is done by slightly
compressing the tissues lives
the glass slide taking the image from
above using latchet for us to microscopy
the loss of c31
does not seem to be severe than looking
at the maximum intensity projection
alone however the pattern becomes very
distinguishable when browsing through
the optical slices one at a time and
when viewed from above the
three-dimensional segment would see if
there is one negative volume here in
yellow looks quite familiar when you
look back to the TEC enlargement but the
true three-dimensional complexity of the
volume in that can only be assessed by
logic force microscopy the ir injury
itself measured via CD 31 negativity
also correlates well with the mouse
hearts ejection fraction reduction after
ischemia reperfusion this was also
measured within the same hearts so
allowing multiplexing of physiological
and legit fluorescent microscopy
readouts and benchmarking against
established methods but enough images
let's watch some videos because this is
why I love flat sheet first microscopy
since it conveys three-dimensional
information much better than any
explanation here we see if CD 31 in
green and autofluorescence in grey the
notice again segmented and displayed in
white we can appreciate as the seeds 31
negative area so when the hole in CD 31
staining and this is traceable and can
be three dimensionally quantified what
you can see here in yellow furthermore c
31 labeling also allows us to trace the
hearts major arteries shown in yellow
and veins shown in blue by
simultaneously tracing the knots we are
able to deduct which arch recently
included during the operation shown here
in red in a moment and this basically
gives us the physiological area at risk
overlaying the traced one in orange here
we see that the two are matching nicely
however overlaying the IR in
gives us a very interesting result only
the ventral part of the heart is injured
while the other side shows no signs of
damage identifying these specific
regions of interest and unlocking them
from further deeper analysis is one of
the main advantages of this system so
what can we do now so we can add ir
injury quantification via CBS CB 31 and
reconstruction of the vessel tree to the
list of what we can visualize Immelt
Aeneas Li in one murrhardt since we
cannot reconstruct the IO since we can
now reconstruct the IR injury in three
dimensions we went ahead and applied a
clinically accepted heart segmentation
normally used for human tomographic
heart data to our tells and data sets
here by the heart is divided into 17
segments by scoring how often I our
injury was located within a certain
segment we created a heat map to
visualize our findings and minds in a
clinically accepted way we can clearly
see that the volume covered by the IR
injury is shrinking when the time of
reperfusion is prolonged going to the
right side the extended that the extent
of the c31 curly region as five days of
reperfusion is larger than the actual IR
injury measured at the time which was
also expected so now we also looked at
the location of immune cells so here you
see c31
in green and the big hole in the micro
vasculature after 24 hours of ribbon
fusion while we fly through we see now
neutrophils in Sian and you can already
see from these reconstructed data that
the cells are lining the eye our injury
but not penetrating into the damaged
tissue using a meristem we were able to
segment and thus count neutrophils in
the entire heart so in combination with
Amaya Carr at function parameters that
we assessed before we can now group the
cells according to the location
interestingly we will find in this high
that only about 1/3 of all the cells are
located at the border of the ir injury
while a substantial amount of cells also
resigned the remote zone so after five
days of reperfusion we see a very
different picture here so the ir injury
is barely visible and the surrounding
c31 kernel region has a slightly
brighter signal compared to the other
restructured micro vessels around it
also the presence of neutrophils here is
strongly reduced which also matches the
fax data this can also be seen in the
segmentation the few neutrophils are
located around the eye our injury in
yellow which consists only of multiple
small volumes it is surrounded by the 31
curly volume and green in which about
40% of all neutrophils reside summing it
up we now have the tool multiplexing
immune cells in infarction parameters
that is also not restricted to the
mirror and heart and this allows us to
identify subpopulations of responding
cells or research their over location so
what we can add to our list is that we
can now show immune cells simultaneously
with all the other parameters assessed
before and that the data can be
presented in a clinically accepted way
besides these points the light Jefferson
microscopy approach lasting about 1.5
days is quite fast compared to all the
other methods you would have to do to
obtain the same result multiplexing
readouts from one animal also fulfils
three our criteria and above all else
you can explore your data find regions
that behave differently than expected
for example the damage we saw in the
beginning that is not how genes you
distributed or you can study the
distribution of immune cells and their
involvement in such phenomena or seen
from a very very technical point of view
you can check if they're not actually
hit the coronary artery when you happen
to wonder why there are no
present example so with the flow
cytometry as an example
you just had to brand the data as an
outlier without exactly knowing why
after having shown you what three
dimensional microscopy can do let me
close with the story from our lab so
when we submitted the paper for the
first time we went dining in a Chinese
restaurant and after dinner I was
presented with a Chinese fortune cookie
that actually read quite fittingly
whatever you do with your entire heart
will bring the best results and with
that I want to close and thank all the
people involved with this project mainly
the supervising PI's and the
hard-working PhDs
with whom I had the pleasure to work on
this project so thank you of course for
your attention
Thank You Simon for that excellent
presentation we will now start the live
portion of live Q&A portion of our
webinar now if you have a question you'd
like to ask Simon and Sebastian please
do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
okay let's get started our first
question
is the balance protocol restricted to
the murine heart yeah so that's a good
question and no it is not so you can
process the whole different kind of of
organs with the balance protocol for
example in the paper we showed that you
can process nicely the very heavy
deauthorize in Oregon deliver and just
by autofluorescence display the vessels
inside the liver but this is not even
restricted to to the mouths in general
yeah
we also did the human a human heart
samples that we got from biopsies and it
was pretty good pretty good clearing
effect at the end it's a bit different
from for the mouth and concerning the
staining part but overall the protocol
for clearing is the same and I think we
also did a few other organs like lung
brain and kidney I mean if you do the
protocol like we did this we intravenous
injection of the antibody you basically
stain the hole Mouse with your desired
antibody so you can process every organ
you like
you
thank you gentlemen our next question
how do you distinguish arteries and
veins just by the morphology
we also we distinguish them by
morphology and where they are located
so veins are normally located on the
outside of the heart muscle whereas the
arteries are not but also veins are
seized everyone let's say dim so they
don't express as much c31
as arteries - and that's why it's kind
of easy to distinguish between them it's
sometimes even a little bit difficult to
see veins but especially when the
vessels are very big then you can easily
distinguish them also it's a signal
intensity thing like the bigger arteries
especially the left coronary artery is
very bright
concerning c31 signal and the Waynes
eyelid denser and the more you go to the
smaller vessels for less CT 4:31
positive signal you get
you
okay Simon I believe this question for
you this is the balance protocol allows
a ssin of endogenously expressed
fluorophores
yeah the direct answer would be no so by
bleaching the heart demure and heart the
endogenous II expressed pure force are
also bleached and therefore their their
fluorescence is quenched and we have in
in the paper so we tested for example
the cubic protocol which is meant to
preserve energy as fresnels and that
works also nicely on hearts it doesn't
get the hearts as clear as a balanced
approach and it nicely shows the
endogenous presence however it
obliterated the aleksef viewers we are
using as the artificial floor force so
that was not an option but that is
something that you can do if you are
focused on the endogenous presence only
we also tested the normal ACI protocol
without leeching at all because VC is
also meant to preserve the endogenous
presence however in the heart with a lot
of other first background and the signal
of the endogenous fluorescence was very
was was not very bright and you could
only see it in in regions where there
was not so much autofluorescence or
muscle tissue in the background but it
was a nice way of showing that the IV
stain that we gave actually marked all
the cells that we also could identify in
in the via endogenous presence so that's
supplemental figure 2
now Sebastian you use CD 31 negativity
for assessment of the IR injury however
CD 31 is only an endothelial marker is
it possible to stain the actual tissue
damage um well it's true that CD 31 only
stays the endothelium and therefore only
the vasculature for heart um and
unfortunately no to my knowledge we
don't have an way to image the tissue
damage the tissue damage itself of the
heart yet of course we are working on it
we have a few suggestions which we are
currently testing in our experiments and
we are very hopeful that in the next
couple of months we will get something
to stay in the tissue damage of the
heart after myocardial infarction
thank you now we have a question coming
in from Thai and Malaysia what kind of
floor for was used for the study yell so
we used CID scene for basically marking
everything that was or fitzy gelatin
better and better for marking the remote
zone
basically everything that was refused
during the infraction and that worked
well also with the bleaching protocol
and else we only used aleksef lures so
mainly the Alex of row six for seven and
also 790 but these are the ones that we
tested since our light sheet system is
also restricting us we have single
wavelength lasers and therefore we can
only test so much of the antibodies but
or they do fewer force but we also
tested was alexa fluor five four six
recently and that also worked well
now we have some great questions coming
in I want to remind our audience for
those questions we do not have time to
answer today they will be answered by
hours and by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration but we're going to
continue with our advice Q&A now we've
question coming in from Mike do you know
if CD 31 expression itself can be
altered by the ischemia um uh well we we
know from the literature that there are
a lot of studies done on CD 31
expression using Spanish astrology
analysis in like the 90s and 80s mostly
in dogs and rabbits to my at my
knowledge um and also for longer periods
of reperfusion when we did what we
showed you today are at the maximum five
days off air perfume and all the our
usual analysis we do after trench four
hours so one day of reperfusion in the
longer periods that were published
earlier like that was like seven days 14
days see if any one expression increases
in the former ischemic zone so V so V
damaged tissue of it which makes sense
as it is Revis later and needs to have
blood supply again um we also kind of
found this when we did the analysis as
five days this like kerley area is very
bright in c31 expression um yeah so I
hope this answers your question
thank you now our next question coming
in from Bill North Western medicine do
the curly CD 31 regions represent
granulation tissue ah it will also be a
question for me um we simply said we
don't know yet granulation tissue is to
my knowledge analyzed we are a matter
clean air and using staining and you
have a lot of fun granulates
um and we don't see that in the light
sheep so we see from your turf lessons
the overall structure of the tissue but
we didn't see a correlating a
correlating image that we see in
histology so simply said to the question
we don't know yet
thank you quite a global audience we
have today we've got a question coming
in from France
Dario's asking which modules of amorous
have been used to obtain the different
3d regions and for the vascular system
so which modules be used from the Amarra
software me ah
Simon I think we only did what is
shipped with regular software Raya so we
use the spot function for example to
determine where the cells are and we
also use the filament tracing tool to
basically determine the the vessel
length density etc yeah and I mean the
general tracing tools to determine the
surfaces so we also some surfaces like
the city we could determine sometimes by
the algorithms that are coming within
hours but for the most part we use the
tracing tool to do it manually a seam
Emanuel's
so sometimes then you have a seeming
manual tool where you can basically draw
regions have automatically
a how is the probability analysis of the
injury done manually
um yeah that's referring I guess to the
17 segment model and yeah there was
manual so we just looked at so we got a
surface in Adobe Illustrator and looked
at the specific regions if there was
infraction for example we gave the one
if there was no interaction we gave it a
zero and then afterwards we did the
probability overall hearts and Alice
thank you now in order to identify
leukocytes do you need to have them
labeled beforehand or can you get
antibodies to stain once you are clear
so what we did in general here is to
inject the antibody is IV into the mouse
just before the mice were sacrificed so
in that case you distribute the
antibodies throughout the mouse without
having to do home on staining or
something like that and therefore Yap we
we just did a life incubation if you
want it that way okay our next question
have you had problems with limited
penetration of antibodies inside the
tissue and if yes how did you overcome
this um so that's again that's a good
question actually we didn't observe like
this a a penetration border or something
that and not really to be honest we
didn't we didn't observe a higher
background first background barrier or
something within the tissue so I
wouldn't say that we have a penetration
problem within the tissue here we also
want stains a mouse but had an
endogenous and expression offer of floor
4 for neutrophils and when we coast
paint with lice extreme antibodies so
also neutrophils and we found like a
100% match of the endogenous signal and
the fluorophore signal so we are pretty
confident to say that the routes we
reused for administration of the
antibody labels all cells we want to see
at least four neutrophils
thank you gentlemen now let's go to this
question coming in from University of
Georgia what other immune cells can you
detect
yeah and that's also something that we
are working on so in the paper there was
also hint on macrophages and of course
we also are interested in other immune
cells like T cells for example or ears
in the fields in their in their role on
infection but so far we are not working
on those or at least we just started to
work on those and don't have information
that we can share right now okay now
what type of light sheet microscopy from
which company lab vision or advice yeah
that's a Lavin microscope or microscope
- and it's equipped with four lasers
single single wavelength lasers or four
and eighty eight that's in this case for
Fitz and five six one we normally use
for the order fluorescence of the tissue
and then we have six four seven and 785
to get a deeper view inside the tissue
and these laser lines are very good to
homogeneously visualize the cells
throughout the sample the microscope
itself is also for eight laser line but
the bet is very far into the green
spectrum and at least for the heart
because it's very dense muscle tissue
autofluorescence is quite a problem in
this region even if we bleach as we do
in our protocol so we only use that for
the area at risk determination using
Fitz because it's it's a very bright the
flow for itself and it's just
overshadows the operations of the tissue
but for single cells yeah identification
we would not recommend to use this font
of a green spectrum
that's also a good thing to add because
we needed the homogenization of the
order for essence to use for example the
Amero faction because that relies on a
threshold that you that you put into and
if you have inhomogeneous image of your
sample then you don't detect for example
cells that are in the middle of the of
the sample whereas you detect others
that are outside that are not really
themselves and this can only be really
assured with the 6 for 7 and 785
thank you now recently there have been
several studies using lectins to label
vasculature do you see any advantage
using CD 31 antibody as compared to
electives
but here we also had a discussion about
that before we did Oct 31 and everything
sailing at least from our point of we
use very low concentrations of antibody
I think we inject 5 micrograms per Mouse
so that's like like a 14th part of the
antibody usually shipped and when we
search for literature for like teen we
found that they use very high numbers of
very high milligram of black teens and
concerning the costs here we found
actually the see very one antibody
approach to be more cost effective and
but yeah you can simply use selecting to
label the the verb escalator and image
them in the light sheet that would be
possible
thank you gentlemen now we have so many
questions that come in but we're almost
out of time so we have to wrap with this
final question now bill comes on a
question his comment ACD 31 is also
expressed by leukocytes and platelets at
ten times lower levels than endothelial
cells also granulation tissue consists
of capillaries fibroblasts and myeloid
cells and is the earliest stage of
healing the capillary network is very
disordered early on and so perhaps is
this what makes it curly
yes so that's also what we think so it
is and we think it's regrowth and
therefore it's curly and completely
disorganized and also to the to the
first part of the question can you
remind me what that was and the thing
about the
yeah um 331 is also expressed by
leukocytes and platelets at some time
yeah thank you so exactly it is it is
expressed but it's so low that we can
distinguish it from from the
autofluorescence basically in the in the
light sheet so the latches you only see
they're very strong signals at a
cellular resolution but you really need
a strong emission in order to detect it
properly and also we place of course
thresholds for detection over it and
that might also cut away every other
expressions that are on a lower basis so
we we have in our studies we never had a
problem that positive signals for the
capillary network or for the veins and
the arteries was also on the same
intensity level than that for for
example our neutrophils that we tested
those always we never we never saw
leukocytes with an expression of CD 31
bed high
thank you gentlemen Simon and Sebastian
do you have any final comments for our
audience yeah sure
so in general I thank you guys from from
that Bruce and Maris for for hosting
this and I thank all of the audience for
participating so well so we got a lot of
questions that we couldn't answer them
also but we will do our job and come
back to you and try to answer all your
questions later after this webinar so
thanks a lot for your participation and
your attention yeah also from my side
thank you for being here and thank you
for interest in our work we we will try
to answer later on everything you might
have taught us
Thank You Sebastian Thank You Simon and
before we go I do would like to also
thank the audience for joining us today
and their interesting questions we had
so many questions come in that we are
not able to get to so claimant and
Sebastian will answer those questions
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration again I
would like to thank Simon Merck and
Sebastian Kosta for their time today and
their important research we'd also like
to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Amar's for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and labret swill alert
you via email when it is available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
we so that's all for now when we thank
you for joining us goodbye from
California and from Essen Germany have a
great day
by